[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller co-host of CBS this
morning Saturday we're dishing up second
helpings of our stories on culinary
trends and feats breakfast in America is
evolving as the next generation of chefs
looks to it as a new frontier of
appetizing experimentation jamie wax
takes us across the country with a look
at innovative ways people are ordering
their most important meal of the day
from traditional bacon and pancakes
breakfast in America while tasty has
lacked the creative focus chefs have
given to lunch and dinner but over the
past few years that has changed in a
major way giving customers a diverse
array of thoughtfully crafted options is
it fair to say that breakfast is the new
dinner well I would say you still got to
eat dinner but why they like about
breakfast now and by breakfast I mean
sort of that weekday meal when I get
talking brunch but you got much more
creative dishes you have much more
healthy dishes Adam Rapoport is editor
in chief of bone Appetit day this is not
the breakfast we're used to though yeah
it's a cliche but you know breakfast is
the most important meal of the day
chefs are now realizing that and they
want to apply their sort of attention to
detail their creativity to this meal and
I think the customers are responding
acclaimed chefs from across the country
are bringing their a-game to the morning
meal this is probably the second most
ordered dish on the menu and many single
out one chef as the pioneer of the
current trend a lot of people credit you
for sort of starting this new movement
is that fair I'll take it squirrel is
the tiny bustling LA restaurant that is
the baby of chef Jessica Koslow I
remember when I was opening squirrel a
very prominent chef here in LA she's
like I will never do breakfast and lunch
there's no margins in it there's no no
alcohol it's a young person's game good
luck when did you know you had really
started something that was culture
changing maybe right when I
in the door I felt at that moment so
many people responded to having a place
that they could have a unique experience
in dining but during the daytime at a
price that was more affordable yet
chateaus working okay I need to all day
from popularizing her twist on avocado
toasts to creating dishes like crispy
rice salad disco and flat tots an
elevated potato pancake Koslow has
created a breakfast menu that is
anything but typical
I think what's interesting about
squirrel is that they proved that a
breakfast can be a moneymaker you can
pack the house and you can also cook
really creatively you can come up with
dishes that are just as tempting and
invigorating and sort of eye-opening as
on a dinner menu
that is delicious okay squirrels
influence is surprised even Koslow
herself it is remarkable to see that
there's an idea here that other chefs
are starting to translate into their own
work that includes michelin-starred
chefs like daniel rose of lu cuckoo in
new york this one is how much they
follow alone in about three days famed
fine-dining maestro
jean-georges Vongerichten was to be
healthy colorful we're good
jean-georges now has breakfast service
in five of his restaurants do you think
this breakfast movement in some ways is
sort of pushed forward by young Chefs
like jessica Koslow totally totally I
mean all those young chef I'm really
starting a new movement and I really
admire them for you know pushing forward
for me break first now become a favorite
meal of the day
really yeah absolutely to Khadija to
cook it to eat it could you imagine
yourself 46 years ago saying no no three
years ago Mason Herefords surprised many
by landing the number one spot on Bona
Patties list of new American restaurants
with his New Orleans sandwich shop
Turkey and the wolf watch on the side
Hereford has also gotten high marks for
his newer breakfast focused restaurant
Molly's rise and shine which he runs
with his fiancee Lauren agudo this is
kind of our piece of Americana breakfast
sandwich it's got
sausage fried hashbrown American cheese
grilled onions and then ketchup this is
sort of one of the weirder dishes
it's a deviled egg tostada with peanut
salsa and refried red bean pickled
peppers onions cilantro this smells
unbelievable yeah that one's advanced
one of my favs even so if you're a fan
of traditional morning fare who finds
all these new choices about overwhelming
Adam Rapoport says not to worry there's
still room for everyone at the table
there's always going to be diners out
there there's always me the basic place
is that we all love to go to to get our
stack of pancakes or fried eggs and
bacon sometimes we just want a greasy
plate of eggs and bacon yeah let's say
you might have had a drink or two the
night before here is like I just need
some hash browns and bacon and eggs and
I'm good after the break we traveled to
Ty town in Los Angeles to see how one
celebrity chef is revitalizing his old
neighborhood we'll be right back
you may know jet Tila from his
appearances on iron chef and chopped but
in Los Angeles he's famous for a
different reason
his family opened what's thought to be
the first high grocery store in the US I
visited Thai town with Tila to discuss
how he's keeping his family's legacy
alive there's a good landmark right like
you know you're in the heart of tight
own you can't visit LA Thai town without
hitting a few of chef jet Tila favorite
haunts so we're gonna eat a trend pair
this room this is the first stop of the
tight town tour all the time I got where
his heritage is showcased through
culture and cuisine what I'll do is I'll
basically like curate the perfect bites
a little cashew chicken a little piece
of cashew a little rice it gets all
pushed into the to the spoon then you
clean off the bite to make sure you eat
and this is how you take a bite and
that's how a Thai person's unique very
efficient Tila put Thai town on the map
when he brought a guy most people
recognized as knowing his way around the
international food scene I told these
businesses and in suppo 6 I was like I'm
bringing this guy named Anthony Bourdain
and then you might get busy and then we
blew these places out that interview
with the late Anthony Bourdain added to
Teela's already growing reputation so
I'm going to do English muffin poached
eggs which ignited on cable TV the
dressing is dish sausage but to
understand Tila you have to go back to
his Chinese and Thai immigrant roots
your family laid the groundwork for Thai
food and America it's kind of a big
responsibility so in 1966 my mom and my
father immigrated to Los Angeles
separately they met a few years later
because it was just it was a little
outpost it was all the Thai people that
were coming and going were based in East
Hollywood right here in Silver Lake
they opened a grocery store in 1972 that
fed a growing immigrant community this
really reminds me
a struggle that my parents endured it
it's not a sad story but it's time to
put it to bed so my mom can kind of
enjoy the rest of her life
his family closed down that location
three months ago but it remains the
treasured example of success that built
a company and seven restaurants I have a
lot of memories of the store
they're all fun memories until you know
I got into my teenage years and I was
just angry at that point cuz I had no
social life and then once I had a
driver's license I did a dude I drove
away as fast as I could
dropped out of school you know and I
mean his working odd jobs went back to
my family
you know and begged him to work and took
over as a manager of the grocery store
while I was there I had a group of non
ties you know that were always wanting
to like they just came back to Thailand
they wanted to cook dishes always asking
how do I make pad thai how do I make
curry how do I make this and they're
like why don't you just do a cooking
class it didn't take long for those
cooking classes to turn into front page
news in the Los Angeles Times and that
was it from that moment the next few
days I got hundreds and hundreds of
phone calls and that made me realize
that there is a need for someone to
communicate not just write recipes but I
did these fun little interactive cooking
classes
lo mein means soft noodles in a nice
really thick gravy which basically I
still do in Food Network today so that
was it that was the moment that I was
like I can do this for the rest of my
life he would eventually open his own
restaurant in Las Vegas
ela and land a guest spot on Iron Chef
America
in iron chef morimoto and I was asked to
battle Masaharu Morimoto toughest iron
chef is scared to death I walked into
kitchen Stadium met Morimoto it was one
of those battles were like no one no one
knew me so they expected me just to get
pummeled it would make really good TV
right get some ratings and where is iron
chef more than one
that would bring him full circle and
give him a platform to share his roots
so is it possible to a cook Pad Thai
like non sweetened patty have you
control the flavors you can make it any
way you want so yeah these days it's all
about control but I figured we'd do a
Chinese dish because that's my real
roots you know I mean grandparents
coming from China we're gonna do a dish
called dan dan noodles control on the
job and in his own kitchen I got to
think about making noodles for dinner
you know what I'm saying and there's
something else about chef Tila oh my god
this is so good it's good right
and it's fast something in his DNA that
just won't stop him from sharing what
he's learned along the way something
that's helped to revitalize this old
neighborhood of his see the face is
changing yeah yeah basically a younger
generations taken over the over it's a
one-of-a-kind food experience where you
learn about Thai culture what's good one
of our bestsellers actually is the Fang
Chi which is I want to say yeah macaroon
but I hate saying then even though it's
a coconut cookies cool a little bit yeah
you're gonna inside a little bit of
crisp on the outside
it doesn't get much sweeter than this
real sticky rice with banana if you like
banana and coconut this is it that's why
you got to come here oh my gosh that
green tea ice cream of course coming up
we take you to a cooking school in
Jordan where ancient foods are being
introduced to a modern audience we'll be
right back
food with ancient origins is helping
women lead modern lives we travel to
Jordan in the Middle East where a
cooking school owner is keeping her
grandmother's favorite recipes alive all
while helping local women join the work
force every one of you is making their
own pots I want you to add just enough
to cover that whole I want it to be like
a nice creamy texture this is actually
my grandmother's house and in Arabic
grandmother's house means Beit City did
you all taste the honey and when she
passed away we decided we wanted to do
exactly what she used to do and teach
guests the dishes that she used to teach
us so what we're gonna do here is the
recipe for Hamas this is my favorite
recipe and it's here that Maria hadn't
Anya teaches people from around the
world how to cook a traditional
four-course jordanian meal who wants to
make dessert let's go through the
recipes here your grandmother's recipe
yes what are some of her favorites them
a little bit and my little bit literally
translated means flipped upside down
it's actually a pot that you make with
rice and meat sometimes chicken
sometimes fish it's a pot that was
prepared by farmers a long time ago
using leftover ingredients today we're
making it with eggplants and
cauliflowers because they are in season
these recipes are some of the Dada
Ananya's earliest food memories learned
right here in her grandmother's kitchen
my mom didn't know what to do with that
so she would bring us here and my
grandmother would put us to work to
prepare lunch you know a lot of women
used to think that it was shameful to
work and your mother worked exactly what
my grandmother you always used to say
was there is no such thing it's actually
shameful if you're not working but
jourdan's a country where women are not
always welcome in the workforce the
World Bank estimates just 22% of women
participate in the labor force compared
with 87% of men I'm very happy to say
that we are all a woman's and all the
women's team it's a living that's
transformed the lives of a marina mall
and majeeda
Muhammad so you feel empowered
now yes but Amidala it gives me freedom
muhannad says to build my own home and
to be more financially independent and
also help other people in my situation
polymerase weed has taught at bait city
for three years
I love cooking she says I love teaching
people how to cook and I love cooking
something that is from my own culture
tourism in Surya Maris weed is Syrian
one of the many displaced during the
civil war what happens when you engage
with people I mean who are not from here
but I lemon I learned from them she says
I take a lot of good beautiful things
from them and we learn from each other
that's true for Australian tourists
Leeanne Tully and Cynthia Robinson this
is a first time we've seen women at work
then all the hotels we've been to it's
men men men men which is good for the
economy but we're wondering where all
the women were now let's talk about how
we boil chicken
beach city is great because it breaks
the barrier so it opens up this platform
of communication with the cooks where
they ask them if they're about the job
and about their religion nobody really
is able to answer these questions unless
you talk to a local among Haddad
Hernandez guests the country's most
famous supporter of gender equality
Queen Rania of Jordan on her birthday
back in 2015 the Queen treated a group
of 40 orphans to a cooking class first
of all Queen Rania the way she portrays
Arab women is very impressive because a
lot of people in the West they don't
know what you're the Indian women are
you know they think that because they're
wearing veils they're you know stepped
on by their husbands they they get told
what to do but this is not actually what
the real deal is still some women who
have worked here have faced struggles at
home one woman was abused by her husband
and when she came here her self-esteem
was shot you know like it was very hard
to bring her back up and the second she
starts giving classes to these men who
are very interested in hearing what she
has to say she automatically her
self-esteem is boosted
and you really see a different woman and
that kind of cultural exchange can make
all the difference I'm so passionate
about what I do I don't feel like it's
work it's so pleasant sitting with the
guests when they come at the end of the
meal because at first it's always
awkward when you meet people mmm
you know it's hard to break this barrier
and the second you start cooking with
them automatically you become friends
you have a shared interest no matter
what's all right back to work
now you work on your salad challah and
they're always in a good mood right
because they're traveling and they're
eating they're never hungry right is
that the word very angry yes okay so
here's to beit's City cheers everybody
after the break we share the stories of
two chefs who have redefined Mexican
food in the United States we'll be right
back
acclaimed chefs Enrique Olvera and
Daniela so tillens are redefining
Mexican food using seasonal and local
ingredients the owners of the hugely
popular restaurant Cosme say their
success is due to a mixture of happiness
and hard work we pay them a visit in New
York City to understand chef Danielle
Soto in it so you wanna pull the face of
the scallop down right you must make the
rounds in her kitchen
a fast-paced production line it's a
formula that works when you have high
energy and when you have passion moving
to a beat that feeds a myriad of palates
it all fits together for this twenty
nine-year-old Mexico City native who
believes that everyone in her domain as
the potential to run the show is amazing
to see that they can have a chance to
run their own kitchens you see the
thirteen ladies I don't think he's go to
any kitchen in America and see this many
women in it they're badasses
they're amazing she's said it not me
sorry that ability to see promise has
come full circle because world-renowned
chef Enrique Olvera saw it in her what
was it about her that impressed you
Daniella was it's always been really
high energy I think she also knows how
to belong to the team but also command
the team which is the heart for chefs to
understand after a chance meeting in New
York he invited her to apprentice with
him in Mexico City
his signature restaurant that was ranked
the best in North America a few years
later he hand-picked her to partner and
run his first New York venture this
restaurant Cosme seen enormous success
is that part of the secret the diversity
happiness the mixture of happiness and
hard work and fun Lachie Keyes is the
best dancer that you ever see playing
host is something both have taken to
whether throwing their customers a
five-year anniversary party or simply
seating President Obama and the first
lady in 2016 even if neither chefs were
there in person my knees was being
burned were you here
I wasn't Mexico luckily their third
partner restaurateur Santiago Perez was
I was called to the front of the
restaurant and they very polite they
asked me late would you have the private
dining room available and the guy gives
me the business card and it's Secret
Service did he click then it kind of it
wasn't immediate you know I wasn't
expecting it what did they think they
loved it and that visit came before
Cosme was named the best eatery in the
US on the world's 50 best restaurants
list for their own unique take on their
hometown food we have razor clams but we
caught it to make that what this duo
seems to have accomplished mixing it up
while keeping it true I mean you're a
classically trained chef and yet you say
most of what you apply in that kitchen
comes from your grandmother's kitchen I
think we all cook from memory and then
you can't create something that you
don't cherish I think it's important for
us to as cooks to understand who we are
I was trained in New York and when I
came back to Mexico I realized I didn't
know much about my own country and
little by little we got to know our own
cuisines all the regional cuisines of
Mexico and we literally fell in love and
true Mexican cuisine is what fuels their
menu you see five similar things which
is the agave corn beans pumpkin pumpkin
Chile's and on and on but we wanted to
showcase Mexican food in New York using
the same idea that we use in Mexico it's
like taking a bath consider this dish
sea bass with it scales fry like Chitra
dawn
I love this dressed with Moho salsa
drizzle it make it nice and green oh
it's gorgeous
yes I don't usually like scales but oh
wait till you try this one mm-hmm
the sauce is everything I do okay what
else do we have here or arctic char in a
tumeric ginger and sea buckthorn sauce
and sea buckthorn is so good for your
skin mmm this is so light it's so not
what people think of when they think of
Mexican when you come to eat it cause
many if you see we like to have things
that are vibrant and and fresh we want
you to come out of the restaurant
feeling happy and alive instead of over
wand and yes loaded
[Music]
now that the duel is conquered New York
Los Angeles is next the recipe for
success they say is simple if you don't
enjoy it you can't persevere just find a
good mentor that will elevate you and
will compliment you and you will learn
nonstop learning non-stop and seeing the
results is really nice
[Music]
you can find more stories like this on
CBS this morning Saturday each weekend
and join us for live news coverage 24/7
right here on CBS n available for free
across all platforms thanks for watching
take care